Iranian State media say four prisoners
have been killed and more than 60
injured in unrest at the notorious Evan
prison in Tehran where political and
Jewel National prisoners are held
video circulating online show a large
fire at the prison complex with gunshots
and explosions heard it follows nearly a
month of protests over the death of the
young Iranian woman Masa amini in police
custody Tom Cheshire joins me now and
and Tom those latest updates confirming
there were some fatalities yeah
confirming from Iranian State media that
four people died of smoke inhalation 61
people injured what the Iranian State
media agency is also saying is that this
fire broke out as a result of a riot
between what they called Thugs and
gangsters that's according to the
governor of Tehran when we saw these
images late last night really striking
you hear that gunfire this huge Blaze
the people who are filming this chanting
death to the dictator it's very hard to
work out what's going on is this perhaps
a Bastille moment for Iran this is a
political prison or are these prisoners
these political prisoners dual Nationals
are also kept they remember nazin Naz
zagari Ratcliffe she was kept in this
prison
are they in danger now the authorities
have shown State media around it look
they say the blaze has been under
control they were showing some of the
results of it today but it is an
incredibly febrile atmosphere in Iran
where it's hard to know what's going on
as you say it is a month since Mata
amini the 22 year old who was detained
by the Iranian morality police she died
in custody authorities said she had an
underlying health condition but her
family says she was tortured and abused
and since then there was immediate anger
those protests they've really spiraled
to include calls for the overthrow of
the state we've seen Oil Workers
striking this is touching so many cities
around Iran the biggest protest really
since 2009 and the so-called Green
Revolution it is very hard to say where
this goes President Joe Biden has said
these protests will not be quieting down
for some time I think it's impossible
not to agree with that assessment
Tom Cheshire thanks so much